The Joe Rogan Experience not only is it
Universal and everybody experiences it
but they all seem to experience it with
the same script you know you're not
worthy you're too old Too Young Too Fat
too thin whatever or let's do something
else let's distract ourselves with
something else so everybody gets the
same thing I mean I always say that it's
it's
um it's a force of nature you know it's
not
personal it's not specific to you even
though it that voice in your head sounds
like it is specific to you it's saying
Joe and then it's hitting you right in
the points that are your sore points you
know yeah but it's really not personal
everybody seems to experience the same
thing
and uh what do you think it is when did
you write the war of art 2002 and in
that time after writing that I'm sure
it's it's obviously been been a very
successful book so
you've had time to think about this like
what do you think is going on like why
are people why why is that a force of
nature what is it um I'll get this is my
lengthy explanation but I'll give you my
theory
if we think of the human so everybody's
got to bear with me this takes a minute
or two
if you think of the human psyche we got
the ego
which is like a little black dot in the
middle of a greater thing that we would
call the self like the jungi itself with
a capital S and the self contains the
collective unconscious all the aspects
of the unconscious right
um the hero's journey the archetypes of
the unconscious all of the sort of
intuitive stuff right when you I would
imagine come up with great comedy
material or any kind of material it's
coming from that self coming from that
deeper place right and even when uh
young or Joseph Campbell describe the
self they have a I have a little diagram
in the war of art where adjacent to this
larger self they'd have like three
arrows and the arrows are coming from
what they call the Divine ground which I
take to mean whatever greater force is
out there you know that that will come
to you so this is a long way of saying
that the ego which is right your eye
part the part that identify eyes with
this body and with the ego wants to be
in control right the ego is where you
drive down to the store you get it
Whatever It Is Right
but when you're trying to tap into that
greater intelligence like if you're
writing if you're trying to come up to
if you're a musician if you're any kind
of creative person you're trying to to
surrender to that self to that greater
self and I feel like
the ego hates that the ego knows if you
make that shift to identify with that
greater self then the ego is out of
business so I think this is my theory
that the ego produces resistance to try
to stop you from from connecting and
trusting and believing because it is a
leap of faith right to get to that other
level wherever it is so the ego says to
you who do you think you are to try to
tap into that thing who do you think you
are to come up with this idea it's been
done a million times better than you'll
ever do it you don't have the chops to
do this you're going to fall on your ass
Etc et cetera Etc or let me distract you
why don't we chase some women why don't
we get drunk why don't we hang out with
our buddies whatever it is but so I
think that what the ego wants is to
maintain its control right and if you
make that shift into the into that
greater self that's when you really are
starting to tap into great stuff that's
where the great stuff comes from yeah
right and that puts the ego out of a job
at least that this is my theory go so
the I think that the ego produces it I
mean it's be interesting it's
interesting sort of animals don't
experience resistance I'm sure they
don't right right but they also because
they experience creativity true but but
they're in that greater world I think
naturally you know right
um they're they're free they're in that
God energy you know an eagle or somebody
that's flying you know you watch like
the tiniest little wings or feathers
even you know control it they're not
thinking about anything right when
they're hunting or whatever it is so
anyway that's that's my theory on what
on What resistance is now Seth Godin you
know he is he's a believer that it's the
the Seth Godin I do not know Seth Godin
is a kind of a marketing Guru one of the
earliest guys on on the on the internet
from way back when when it first began
and uh it's a great um
teacher of marketing and stuff like that
and also a wonderful guy in his areas in
the sense that he is
highly ethical dude like when he talks
about
um businesses startups and all the
things that he's kind of uh helping
people with
ethics is a huge part of it so I really
respect the guy and he's a great deep
thinker too now he thinks it's what he
calls the lizard brain the amygdala
which I'm not even sure what that is I
guess it's the reptile brain at the back
of your head that that's what's
producing something that wants producing
resistance but
anyway I respect his thinking on that
but I think it's what I just explained
to you what you're saying makes a lot of
sense and the the ego whatever that
thing is that it's it's so interesting
how it's not able to see that it would
actually benefit the ego
if you didn't have resistance yes which
is really weird that's weird isn't it
yeah because if if the ego was wise and
and had like foresight it could see the
future oh if we just like just give in
and relax and relinquish control then
we're going to come up with better stuff
and our life's gonna be better be able
to buy a nicer house yeah you know maybe
be able to go on trips your work will do
well everything will be good it's a d
it's a deep subject because also if you
think about
the ego's view of what life is
you know I'm going to go into some deep
stuff right clarify just the ego has a
whole View
the ego believes that this material
world
is all there is right yeah the ego
believes in death the ego believes that
when his body dies we die right the ego
believes that this flesh can be hurt you
know can be maimed can be broken etc etc
so the ego is naturally lives in fear I
think that the the predominant emotion
of the ego if we're living in the ego
which is 99 of people do our predominant
emotion is fear right and fear uh even
though we might not know it fear of
death which is kind of why people want
to achieve I think right let me make a
name for myself blah blah blah why
people want to have children or children
will live on why they have insurance why
they try to succeed and have a big house
and this and that and the other thing
right that's all sort of coming out of
out of an out of a uh a mindset of fear
whereas this giant self in my opinion
the bigger self that is connected to the
thing
its predominant emotion is love if you
ask me now the ego another thing the ego
believes is that I am separate from you
right we are all separate individuals
right I could hurt you and it won't hurt
me that's what the ego thinks right
that's why so much of the evil that
happens in the world comes out of that
right we can torture these sons of
[ __ ] and it won't happen to us right
nothing bad will happen to us but the
self believes exactly the opposite once
you get into that deep level right that
we are not separate from one another
that you and I are bound together in
some kind of way along with all of
humanity and all of the animal life and
all of the planet all of the oceans and
all of that and so the predominant
emotion in that self is the emotion of
love so the ego this is my belief anyway
the ego being centered in fear is going
to try to hang on to what it's got right
if the ego thinks that it's living our
life it's calling the shots it's going
to hang on to that you know out of out
of fear and won't that's why I think
it's so strong resistance is so strong
when when you the closer you get to
moving into that self into that greater
space like if you're sitting down and
trying to write a novel and you get into
a kind of a flow of it that's what the
ego is really afraid of because it
starts to kind of empowering and
intoxicating experience the ego says to
itself [ __ ] if this guy stays over here
very long he's never going to go back to
you know to where I polish call the
shots so I think that's why it it makes
itself it puts it such a an intense shot
at you to stop you from getting there so
this greater self
what is if like what do you think that
is
if the greater self is all about love
and the greater self is what recognizes
the connection between all of us what is
the greater self okay it's a great
question I know that you're a guy that's
into psychedelics to some extent right I
mean when you now my only experience
with psychedelics is back in the 60s you
know so I haven't done any of the stuff
that people are doing now you want some
no thank you I'm too old for that you're
not too bad but one of the things that
you know existence that's resistance
psychedelics maybe so but one of the
things that you know from LSD or from
mescaline or anything like that right is
you suddenly see a whole other world
that was not there before right even
though you're looking at that wall all
of a sudden that wall becomes so
beautiful right that you you can't even
say anything except wow right so that's
I believe I I would I was thinking in
those moments this must be the way Jesus
sees the world or the Dalai Lama sees
the world or or God sees the world and
when I come back to my regular self
and I see this kind of normal shrunk
down world that's not the real world
right there's another world that's
greater and so that's sort of my feeling
about it Joe that that that when the
self when you enter that there is a
greater World we're living in that
greater world right now we just can't
see it you know we're just we just see
what's in front of us and I think
another aspect of it to me you would
know a lot more about this than I do
being more in the present of this is
that if you're living in that kind of
psychedelic world you really can't drive
a car you really can't operate heavy
equipment you really can't handle the
stuff you have to handle you can't do
your taxes right so in order to kind of
live you do have to sort of shrink
shrink that world down right to to you
know push the the all the beauty aside
and all the amazing [ __ ] aside but that
doesn't stop the fact that that stuff is
there right I always wonder
what was it like before we were born and
what's it going to be like after we die
are we going to live in that world are
we going to enter that world again and
what is that what what will that be like
do you think that this narrowed down
world that you're talking about when you
when the psychedelics wear off do you
think that's an artifact of the cold
hard reality of being an animal living
amongst predators and other other
violent human beings on Earth where in
order to survive in order to raise your
children and protect your village and
provide food to each other you kind of
have to have this very
simplistic just just as you said
narrowed down this is different where
you can't just wax euphorically about
the the concept of the universe and life
and and and love I do yeah I do believe
that yes and I think that's why again
like what I was saying about the ego
being being dominated by the emotion of
fear right and also our parents right
and our society our school tool
everything for our own good as we're
kids growing up tells us all that right
it kind of indoctrinates us into that
world for our own good right it wants to
protect us you know on your way walking
to school nobody's going to beat you up
blah blah blah right
um so yeah I do think that's the case
it's kind of a strange world isn't it
that God created for us and on the one
end there's this beautiful other
dimensional reality out there but then
there's this hardcore world of predators
you know in order to you know like what
did you just have on Instagram today a
alligator taking off the leg off a deer
I mean that's that uh did I you don't
even know if what was there but it's
there we just saw it a few minutes ago
but I had it on Instagram yeah I think
so
yeah there was a crocodile that took a
pig and snapped it in half oh is that
what it was like like that yeah I didn't
see it terrifying video but yeah that's
the world right the guy gave us sure
yeah